what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here today to do
our use our Monday use which is to watch
from our friend Paul the heavy spoilers
The Last of Us episode three he sticks
breakdown reaction I think I sound just
like it I almost thought you were him
for I was about to say oh yeah but don't
make an ass out of you or me Greg okay
Theory time theory time very time all
right guys we'll leave a like if you
haven't seen her episode three reaction
it's up here on the Chanel right now
John and Terrors will be up man Yana
that means tomorrow in Spanish right
that means tomorrow and Pedro Pascal
let's get to it
[Music]
now the first thing I want to do is go
through Belle's story in the PlayStation
classic for anyone who hasn't played it
this will kind of give you an idea of
just how much things were changed and
what we originally had first time round
as always we will be saving future
spoilers for the end of the video and if
you enjoy it then please hit the thumbs
up button and don't forget I've already
done it done it all done by the way huge
thank you for clicking this you're
welcome are you voicing over
[Music]
in the game you arrive in Lincoln having
just escaped the state building this
culminated in Tessa's death and Joel and
Ali fled into the Subway after being
chased by fedra you never really got to
catch your breath and on the other side
of this when you slow down Joe refused
to talk about Tess this showed just how
cold he was and even upon reaching Bill
he just played along that she was alive
without ever correcting him now the way
that Joel and Ali met with him was that
they sprung one of his traps which led a
gel being suspended upside down in one
of the tensor scenes in the game sworn
by infected you had to defend yourself
in Ellie as they tried to tear you apart
this is when bill came in and after
making your way to his church you laid
low for a beer before Manning a plan to
get a truck battery this was from a
military Caravan that had crashed into a
nearby School in an area that bill
normally refused to go to this was due
to that side of town being teeming with
infected but because the old Joel a
favor they decided to head out there
overloaded with infected you found that
the battery had already been taken and
he had to burst you to school before
make
Frank who had made a break for it unlike
the show Frank couldn't stand Bill
anymore and when the Caravan crashed he
devised the planet take the battery on
the way out though he'd been bitten and
he ended up unaliving himself before the
infection took its toll you see there
was something really interesting about
the way it's played out here where I
don't have the TV show right no the gay
man drew the game listen to what I'm
saying sorry sorry I'm saying Andrew
it's pretty much alluded that bill and
Frank perhaps were in a relationship why
I say alluded is because it it's the way
it kind of transgresses in the actual
game is it seemed like it was sort of a
secret between Bill and Frank it's not
something where it seemed like their
relationship was super open about it you
could have just you know translated as
no they were just friends but they were
maybe secretly gay it didn't seem like
they were an openly gay couple I always
interpreted as they were gay just when
he said he was my partner I know you
could take that in in other ways but
that's just how I took in the way he how
you know the the sorrow it's just my
homophobia listen to me listen to the
game Greg listen to what the game is
saying sorry no no he's a Catholic I
hear a partner I feel oh business yeah
exactly I mean business if it wasn't a
post-apoc alyptic world I might have
probably
probably but yeah also too you could see
kind of the sorrow you know and how sad
bill was at when he first saw him and
then also when he got that note like he
looked deeply hurt right so that's
that's why I took it that way he laughed
a note behind the bells saying how much
he hated him and after finding his truck
you pop the clutch and headed out to
Pittsburgh now that's the way the game
played out with it being heavily focused
on action and a massive deviation from
what we get here I'll be going through
How Stuff compares to the game as we get
into it but that's kind of a bird's eye
view of how it plays out so you can
instantly see how different it is to the
show now we begin with Joe dipping his
hand into a river and there's a tension
drawn of the cuts on his knuckles from
smashing that God's face in like a new
like button Ellie very much represents
the daughter that he couldn't save and
the lesson that he learned from this is
the wrong one and he might end up
thinking that violence is the way to
achieve things I suppose it probably is
the right lesson in this world but he
clearly wrestles with losing his cool
like this now this idea of losing one's
control is juxtaposed by the stone
stacking that we see him carrying out
typically you'd see something like this
in a spa and stone stackings carried out
because it has a spiritual connection to
the Earth but also takes time and effort
to create the balance in the pile and
this Stone stacking seen as being
something that showcases one's patience
however it goes beyond that and it's a
practice that's being carried out in
several cultures dating all the way back
to ancient Mongolia Stone Stacks were
also used for navigation in rural areas
due they're not being signed posts to
roads out in the woods or by Rivers I
think it's more for the former reason
but I I just thought I'd bring that up
too but you know it's also ironic Joel
is from Texas and in Texas stacking
rocks and Texas state parks actually
isn't allowed so perhaps it goes in
conjunction with him being rebellious I
don't know Texas and stacking rocks
isn't allowed so you know what it goes
it stays in the real rejects reaction to
heavy spoilers video as some type of
contribution to this fact about stacking
rocks now that 10 miles outside of
Boston in the woods which is a location
that you start up at before traveling
until to Lincoln now he's now wearing a
green coat with a red hoodie and this is
something that she'd done later on in
the game once we hit the winter sections
though Joel's pretty [__] off from her I
like the touch that they've added here
which is that she's using his jacket for
a blanket at this point he's still
reeling from the death of Tess but due
to being a close book he refuses to open
up he still clearly cares though and he
tosses her some food which leads into a
conversation that plays out slightly
differently in the game they kind of
change up the positioning of the lines
and Joel says not to bring up Tess here
whereas he does it at the end of the
episode in the show
hey look
um
about Tess
listen about tests
I don't even know here's how these
things gonna play out
you don't bring up tests ever
rule one you don't bring up tests ever
exactly I love these side by sides yeah
actually just keep our histories to
ourselves secondly
don't tell anybody about your condition
well too you don't tell anyone about
your
condition they think you're crazy
they'll try to kill you you see that
bite mark they won't think it through
they'll just shoot you
and lastly you do what I say when I say
it rule three you do what I say when I
say it
are we clear
we clear
repeat it
sure repeat it
what you say goes
you see what I loved about seeing this
side-by-side comparison is whatever
actors are doing a scene there's one of
the common terminologies is what is the
actor's prior moment going into it what
happened before this scene that we are
doing because that often can be a
dictation of how you're going to be
going about your performance in that
currency right even though the lines are
pretty much the exact same way the
placement of it gives it a completely
different prior moment and leading into
it so the delivery from the actors is
going to be very different type of
energy and tone and mood while a little
bit similar in some variations of the
levels of course it's also feels like a
very different kind of scene because of
how we got to the scene in the Show
versus the exact moments leading up to
it in the game itself so I think having
a cool side by side by like that makes
it feel like oh we're getting like two
very different scenes by that point I
know what I mean yeah that's a very good
observation because as you were just
saying in the video game we get to the
that moment right after what happens to
Tess whereas in the show we get to that
moment after a lot of traveling yeah a
lot of traveling so they're a little
more calm and they're you know it's not
just uh they had not just been through
an emotional ordeal so it's really cool
seeing the side by side and again what I
love about these actors is they're not
imitating they're making it their own as
well but yeah that's a great observation
you made thank you that's why I'm here
and also to point out that in Texas
stacking rocks is illegally at the parks
I'll remember that if I ever go there do
not stack right that's the only crime
I'm not going to commit is stacking
rocks either way giola is completely
shut off and they hike for four hours
before passing through the woodlands one
of the things that's never really
touched upon about the last of us is how
much it focus is on the beauty of Nature
and how once Humanity's been whittled
down the Earth can reclaim the land
beautiful apocalypse but uh cordyceps
themselves could very much be seen as a
defense mechanism for Earth and tying
back at the climate change comments this
could be the planet finding a way to get
rid of us without creating Skynet big
Theory time for that but Ellie asks Jill
how he got his scar and he says it's
from the early days when someone shot at
him and missed though he says that he
shot back it is possible that this could
have come from the night Sarah died and
it may have been a stray from The
Soldier's bullets the scars up beside
his Temple and I think this would
explain a lot if he was reminded of that
night every time he looked in the mirror
and they traveled to Cumberland I
thought that was the same thing it's a
real store in America so I learned
something about our cousins every day
this is a stash house where gels Left
Behind supplies but the real talking
point here is the Mortal Kombat 2
cabinet Ellie mentions her friend he
knew everything about this game and this
is likely Riley who was touched upon in
episode one I can't tell you how much
money this machine swallowed seriously
Park when I was a kid and me and my
cousin Mark used to spend most of our
time on a Saturday getting our asses
kicked by scorpion yep Ellie brings a
Mileena and how she used to rip off her
mask to reveal her horrendous teeth
which is one of the most memorable
fatalities from the game but this scene
actually falls from the game it's Angel
knives instead of Mortal Kombat 2 2 we
have a cabinet for the in-universe
fighter called the turning and that is
the character Angel knives and Ali
describes her fatality much in the same
way that she does for myelina here would
you play this before
you ever play this one
I had a friend who knew everything about
this game no
but I had a friend that knew everything
about this game this is one character
named Elena who takes off her mask and
she has monster teeth and then she
swallows you whole and Barks out your
bones
apparently there's this character called
Angel knives who'd
what was it
she'd punch a hole through your stomach
before kicking your head off
I'm never a big fan of these things
obviously Warner Brothers on the rights
to Mortal Combat and with him owning HBO
as well they probably gave them that
sweet sweet corporate Synergy deal so
we're not registered talking about this
although the original Last of Us game
didn't contain a poster for the game the
Remake did and they obviously released
that look you're not talking about
Street Fighter in the show we'll discuss
more on our super spoiler section how
this arcade cabinet could pop up again
so make sure you stay locked until the
end if you've completed the games way to
keep your retail hasn't been out this
way in a couple of years and later on we
discovered that he only went out there
once in the game Joel had never actually
been out of Bill's Town personally so
I'm going out there was a bit of a
desperate move Ali heads out into the
back room and you eagle-eyed viewers
might spot a safe code up beside the
door
which I Googled to see if it was a code
used in the game unfortunately it's not
I think this is just an Easter egg to
the codes you'd find dotted about the
game that would lead to upgrades and
extra ammo in the back Ellie discovers
their own secret with there being a door
basement now in there she finds some
things that you'd normally run into the
game like lockers and filing cabinets
with them usually having items lying in
them here we find someone trapped under
the rubble with a fungus growing out of
the top part of their head this is
completely grown out of one of their
eyes and as the clicker showed the
cordyceps attached to the brain and then
grow up from there the brain of course
controls the body so doing this allows
them to alter our behaviors and desires
once a crowded ended up beating the eyes
and those further along in the infection
chain ended up blind like the clickers
are now in our first video we discussed
how the creative team wanted the
infected to seem almost sympathetic
there were times when you'd find them in
a corner subbing away to themselves when
you think about it having a parasite
bury its way into your brain is a
horrifying thing to experience this idea
of them being tortured Souls is
definitely apparent yeah I don't think
we can show because of demonetization
but Ali Cuts them open and we see how
his flesh has very much become the plant
you know I think that scene actually
executed that well because we haven't
come across anything like that in the
show yet where there's an infected and
they're like crying in the corner and
stuff which is a really common thing to
encounter in the video game itself but
with this stalker uh trapped another
Rubble there was something about that
for like I was looking up at her where I
was like is Ellie feeling sorry for this
guy because I'm feeling a little bit
sorry for this guy right now even though
I know you know if he's not on the
rubble he's just gonna attack her of
course but I did feel that sympathy that
apparently the game developers didn't
want you to somewhat feel for them yeah
because whenever you're playing the game
at least from my point of view I I never
felt sympathy whenever I killed him yeah
you feel bad for the human that was once
in there of course but they're no longer
I don't they're no longer that human
anymore but yeah no giving a sympathetic
moment to I believe that was a stalker
that was uh that was an interesting
position to uh not only put you know the
viewer there in that moment but also
just giving Ellie her first kill because
she'd never experienced that as well he
then takes Mercy on him by ending his
suffering and she also stashes his
assault rifle like I said last week I've
always thought of him more as a pistol
and shotgun guy and with that not being
much Emma the wild for it it's
completely pointless carrying it I let
him stashing it here is important and it
also ties into why he doesn't take any
of Bill's guns Joel believes he's
returning here and he still sees Ellie
as a job rather than being a person
could have some effect on him and it may
end up changing the way he looks at the
world and they come across a downed
plane which Ellie of course hasn't seen
before she's lived her entire life in
the qz and it wasn't exactly Turkish
Airlines promising flights to Gotham
this reminded me a lot of the scene from
Steven Spielberg's War of the Worlds
when the characters
Ellie is fascinated by people getting to
go up in the sky but Joe points out the
tragedy in it and his life was of course
massively Changed by one the opening of
episode 1 had the scientists talking
about how disease could travel fast now
due to airplanes and one crash down
taking out Joel Tommy and also Sarah's
ride
I dreamed about flying the other night
oh yeah
goodbye
so I'm on this big plane full of people
and everyone is screaming and yelling
because the plane's going down
so I walked the cockpit opened the door
there's no pilot
I try to use the controls but
I obviously have no clue how to fly a
plane
right before we crash
I wake up
I've never been on a plane
isn't that weird overrated well you know
dreams are weird now the meaning of this
is difficult to descend do you think
that it gives insight to her character
Ali thought she was a passenger on a
plane and that someone was in control
and also guarding her this could be
represented by fedra who raised her
Marlene who was actually looking after
her and then Joel who of course took
care of her now these figures in her
life could be representative of the
pilots but I personally think that they
represent the passengers the plane goes
crashing down and this is mirroring the
fall of the world around her she gets up
to see there's no pilot and then this
shows that no one is actually in control
and those are the passengers are unable
to fly the plane because no one really
knows what they're doing I think growing
up at all kids yeah they think adults
have got their [__] together and then
when they become one they realize that
no one actually knows what's going on
which I think this conversation could be
signaling
foreign
Ellie asks about how the entire world is
stabilized and she talks about people
sitting in restaurants finding Dandy and
then the first bite happening this was
something that we sort of seen play out
last week with a boo Ratner being picked
up by the government in a restaurant
before she was taken to examine a bite
victim early bets it was actually
monkeys who spread the disease and this
might be another 28 Days Later don't
they mention that in the game yeah not
going into spoiler territory but there
is a reference in the video game in
regards to monkeys which I won't
elaborate further in but if we do reach
that point in the show I'll go more into
detail about that the monkey references
a little more it's the wizard of it's
The Wizard of Oz it's the flying monkeys
in just a 28 Days Later reference never
seen it come on Paul I hope you
mentioned in your spoiler section if you
don't we got Andrew here to take you
down now what I also think they could be
setting up here is something coming down
the line although we will say before you
know by now for the super spoiler
section that must be it
Jill talks about the best theory for how
they managed to spread so easily and
this is something that was also touched
upon last week he correctly guesses that
the cordyceps mutated and they somehow
got into the food supply last week we
heard how they changed to the flower and
grain Factory which we discovered acted
as the perfect substrate this in
technical terms as I mean it has
specific enzymes that plants can live on
and here a change before spreading out
further if it got into the processing
units in the factory then it could
spread into bread and cereal which would
then be eaten by people across the
planet I really hope this notion carries
on throughout the season and I'd love it
if we went to a store and saw the
shelves picked there except for the
cereal and bread aisle thank God it
didn't infect the toilet paper because
we all know how people love to grab that
now Jill remembers the specific date it
happened which was on a Friday September
26th is because it was of course his
birthday but beyond that it's also day
Sarah died a further up The Path they
come across several skeletons the game
would have the odd scene like this with
red and blue clothing standing out
amongst the corpses we never really know
what happened at these places in the
game but Joel fills us in on them how
much
but the difference here is that they
promised safety at a qz if there wasn't
room they'd take people into the
countryside and fire upon them and I
think this scene could be taking
inspiration from the ending of The Great
Escape this is also something that was
carried out in the Holocaust and later
on Bill even describes the government as
being Nazis and the government are all
Nazis the government are all Nazis well
yeah now but not then also with a Great
Escape I swear if someone's kicking off
in the comments about spoilers for that
I'm gonna go mental it's been out 60
years I've never seen it you did spoil
it for me though Paul now Joel says that
they were killed so that they couldn't
pass on the infections about why this
was done people rebelled against Federer
and scoring a group like this could
potentially lead to an uprising for
example if they promised safety at the
qz and then said you couldn't come in
It's Gonna annoy a lot of people and it
could lead to some backlash and we then
take focus on a rainbow blanket in a
child's body which takes us into our
major flashback for the episode I love
how the series has done this and every
episode so far has had a major part of
the past filled in with elements that
weren't present in the game now we've
seen what happened to the survivors days
after the outbreak and this is all new
stuff to show us exactly what it was
like X's are painted on doors and in the
game you'd often come across these
houses
hidden by hunters that was marked with
an X so if you're playing through the
game right now and make sure you look
out for that one every single person is
being given a mandatory evacuation now
this and we see this in front of a civil
war Monument along with fighting against
the infected The Last of Us is also
about Man vs Man and this brother versus
brother Monument could be heading
towards that this sign also popped up in
the game and when you entered Lincoln
you could spot it in the middle of the
street the irony is they'd actually be
safer in their town as they end up being
killed when they could have lived out
the rest of their lives here in the game
you could see how dangerous Lincoln was
due to it being overrun by infected and
here I was kind of thinking I don't know
why John test didn't just stay here Bill
kind of shuts down the idea but it's way
better than the qz and I'm sure that you
know a couple more bottles of wine that
I could have convinced him it was a good
idea anyway at this point we're
introduced to Belle played by Nick
Offerman we see him surveilling the tan
3 CCTV and he's very much an end of the
welder actually used to work with a
woman whose son thought doomsday was
coming and apparently spent years
collecting tins of beans little did he
know it was toilet roll toilet roll he
needed to horde as their bloody quick
now they really recaptured the look of
Belle and along with his trusted shotgun
he looks pretty identical to the game
he's got weapons lining the wall and
collections of guns and I'm a magazine
along with a machete his weapons how
he's introduced in the game with him
cutting off the head of an infected
that's got Joel on the ground he ends up
Dunning his gas mask which he also wore
in that and we see his bunkers cleverly
located beneath the chest of drawers
without seeing the gas masks back which
is something he too worn the PlayStation
counterpot as we know those spores have
been removed from the series do the
Creative team worrying that everyone
would be asking why they aren't
constantly done in gas masks again I
don't think people would have wanted it
could have also been for the budget or
to see the actors faces as they're
terrified by the infected later on we
also see this room has a workbench in it
he's pulled directly from the game and
they're what players use to upgrade
their weapons also forgot to mention
last week that we actually had another
nod to the game when Tess and Joel went
into their backpack they swung them off
their shoulders and got on the ground
found it just like how Joel does every
time he wants to craft something true
there's also the magazines that we see
throughout the episode in the game these
were used for upgrade trees and they
helped you unlock special skills Gotta
Love little Easter eggs like that where
the way it's even being played like Joe
getting on the ground and putting it
down you're so in the moment it's so
subtle they're not even registered like
oh that's like how he does it in the
game yeah I mean there's been plenty of
times I feel like throughout these three
episodes where we've had moments like
that we're like the guitar ah there's
that but yeah there are other moments
where you know we get someone amazing
like Paula to point out no it's there's
the backpack moments like oh my goodness
they were so subtle about it I didn't
even realize but again you just saw in
the moment I love the uh the upgrade
like right when I saw that one I did
notice but yeah I'm just again the
attention to detail on this show and I'm
glad they got Neil druckman to work on
this but it's gray day now as Bill comes
out of the ground we can also see that
he has a wine rack and you're ready to
wind stolletta showing how much it means
to him when he serves a bottle to Frank
prank is played by Murray Bartlett and
you might recognize him as playing
Armand in the White Lotus he's a
completely opposite Bell and we can see
this in many ways bill is kind of out of
shape and this is seen later on when the
pair go jogging together this actually
speaks to their time in the apocalypse
as Bill's been kicking his feet up and
living it up or as Frank has been
fighting to survive out there it's
pretty much survival of the fittest
meanwhile Bill's in a safe place where
it's 1.40ish per gallon of gas bring on
the poster box take me there take me
back seriously now we see that Bella's
door has an accident with markings
around it like the one before these are
pulled from the game but they've also
appeared in real life and during
Hurricane Katrina they could be found on
doors these to note how many are inside
which team search did and the date that
they did we can also see that Bell's
House was built circus 1793 which makes
it from pre-civil War era this further
adds to his old school Persona and how
he doesn't trust the government he's a
regular old one
anyway the town is completely empty now
and we get a sort of last man on Earth
situation with them basically being able
to do what he wants it is funny because
while he's not playing Ron Swanson he is
playing this certain way like this could
have been Ron Swanson in the apocalypse
there's versions of have you seen Parks
and Recreation never watched that the
only clip I've ever seen from that show
is the one uh the Kim Kardashian joke
that Chris Pratt made on the outtake
everyone loves a good comeback story
right Kim Kardashian in the video she
gets she gets corner back I think oh
have you seen that yeah that's a very
funny joke well let me try to contribute
to the video then while you do that
whatever this is
yeah Francois there's even an episode of
Ron Swanson it's a very anti-government
there's a whole episode where he's
trying to go off the grid but he is like
free from the government and everything
by the beginning this could have been
Ron Swanson in here but this is not the
same kind of character so you're saying
Neil druckman watched Parks and Rec and
went that's bill yeah in some ways
montages like this are a staple of
post-apocalyptic movies and most
famously I remember the one from the
Dawn of the Dead it went on a shopping
spree in the mall but it's also
something that popped up in 28 Days
Later with them going into the
supermarket and just going well with all
the food now this is to the backdrop of
the song yes I'm Coming Home by
Fleetwood Mac it makes it really a beat
and I think the entire point of Bella's
story is a show that you can have fun
and find love even in the apocalypse
Tess and y'all were a couple but they
never really seemed like they were in
love and instead I think the apocalypse
pushed them together so they had safety
in numbers Joel has completely shut
himself off and to me the stuff with
Bill and Frank could be a reflection of
how he needs to open up a bell takes a
speed boat fills up several barrels of
petrol and goes while at Home Depot this
is to build his traps which we didn't
end up in carrying in the game when you
first entered Lincoln normally you'd be
walking along would notice a tripwire
which you'd then have to set off either
by luring in an infected or throwing a
brick at it
when he handed his home and I love
dropping these things throughout the
game you know just a little trick for
them now an infected setup one later by
pulling a trap by it and bill says it
doesn't get all you're definitely right
and yeah take me back to that game and
the first thing he does is secure the
area get some alcohol and build a
generator to power the town he's created
a nice little life for himself and it's
during this time that he ends up meeting
Frank a bill really was someone who was
used to being alone and people who
prepare for the apocalypse tend to do so
by themselves it's rarely a group ever
because it requires paranoia and
shutting oneself off in order to survive
Frank shows that he should open up to
people though and if it wasn't for him
then he'd never know Tess and Joe four
years later we hear the song White Room
by Cream which has a lot of meaning that
applies to the episode the song is about
someone stuck in a white room by
themselves and here they face depression
and also loneliness bill of course as a
White House and is submerged by most of
the buildings he's walled himself up
from everything and now he's alive he's
not really living for anything this
reminds me a lot of Alexandria from The
Walking Dead but there's no other people
around and therefore it's not really the
rest of civilization and the homie is a
poster for don't tread on me and this
also brings a lot of meaning with it Not
only was it a Metallica song but it was
also a political slogan used in the
American Revolution the dates all the
way back to the Bible and in Latin the
phrase is Noli me Tangier this means do
not touch me and it was said by Jesus to
marry Magdalene after his resurrection
the bomb between physical and spiritual
was at its highest during this point and
it came across more as a warning to it I
think it's more aligned with a Metallica
song as it's the same as the cover that
was used and that song Had lyrics like
Give me liberty give me death a
rattlesnake imagery yeah Benjamin
Franklin who said that the animal was a
great symbol for the American Spirit
anyway a trap is triggered and out in
the Holy dug Bell finds Frank believing
it's its own trap bill is immediately
suspicious and in the game it was
difficult to not immediately have
paranoia when he came across someone you
I do really appreciate whenever you go
out of your way to point out
thematically what some of these more
production design details ultimately
entail because you know I love the idea
of like diving further in and that adds
further more to who this person is as a
character and the world that they
inhabited even before the apocalypse and
what dictates them for where they're at
now so I think that's actually pretty
cool to have some type of symbolism like
that there that if you were to read into
it you'd find out oh this actually is a
very specifically chosen thing because
you're like all right yeah we'll build
like classic rock makes sense but
there's a Metallica poster right there
then you find out oh this is why this
character would have this one there
that's something that like people who
develop games really think about it so
have that here in the show itself I
think is actually a really nice nugget
that should not be overlooked the don't
tread on me I mean I agree with
everything you just said but the other
point where he was mentioning you know
the don't touch me kind of thing I
always felt that was more of in Bill's
personality too from what we remember in
the video game where like remember how
freaked out and crazy he would get on
Ellie whenever she would touch anything
invade any of his personal space or
belongings kind of felt like it was kind
of both ways on that he says that he set
out from Baltimore qz which we learn is
now more now we never visit this
location in the game where the
characters instead heading more in a
Northern direction of Pittsburgh
according to Google Maps it's a six day
walk non-stop between Baltimore and
Boston so we can see why Frank's lost so
many out in the road Bill decides to
take him in and this all happens after
using a scanner to get the all clear now
they have dinner together and Bill ends
up feeding him rabbit these were animals
the characters had to hunt in the game
because obviously yeah the farm industry
is gone it's complete opposite to what
he's just gone through and the man's
been out on the road facing in death and
I was sipping wine and eating rabbit he
takes to the piano and here he plays a
song a long long time by Linda ronstad
this contains lyrics like I can see I'm
gonna love you for a long long time
which is something he sounds terrible
too you sound terrible mate you sound
terrible but it does play in the episode
now Bill takes to it instead Annie
manages to sing it perfectly it kinda
sums up the pair I think with one being
chaotic Razia there is highly ordered in
control the lyrics of course the
relationship that they're about to be in
and for the next 45 minutes we see the
rest of their lives play out bill is
different in the game I think because
he's way more open or as in the last
diversity he looks down on Joe for
caring about people and in this world
that sort of shit's good for one thing
getting you killed
so you know what it did wasn't the [__]
up and I realized it's got to be just me
we never really see his relationship
with Frank and I have spoken to people
who play the game without even picking
up on it at all Frank wasn't ever
something about this episode in
juxtaposition of that completely
develops their relationship now it is of
course share similarities with his game
counterpart like how he kicks off about
Resource Management why
he does that in the final letter too and
we find out that he's the one who
reached out to Tess and Joel they come
over for a garden party and Bell's
thesis is a bad idea further diving into
how close stuff he is from Humanity he
brings a gun to the dinner table and
Joel says we can't help each other and
get that gun out of my face this of
course goes beyond just being cautious
and the pair of course both ready to
flip at a moment's notice if this
situation calls for it I left alone and
Joel offers to get more material to make
the fence last the rest of their lives
together in the game it was clear Tess
was more the point of contact which is
why Joel will never visited Lincoln
personally a test and Frank talk about
using the radio again but they decide to
use a code in case anyone's listening in
as we know from episode 1 this becomes
the 60s 70s and 80s music which also
plays in what they discover at the end
now Jill warns that Raiders will
eventually swarm the town and after
Frank makes a strawberry garden we see
this playing out in the night reminded
me a lot of I Am Legend and keeping out
Raiders is something that's too mirrored
in the game moving through linking and
you actually only ever encounter the
infected because Bill's got such a tight
leash on everything after being shot
Bell tiles Frank to call Joel as he's
someone like him who's able to take care
of weaker people this is of course why
he was entrusted with Ellie and we very
much have this Dynamic of a strong
Survivor protecting a weaker less
equipped one Bell survives though and in
a twist of fate Frank is left in the
wheelchair who then jump to 2023 and
finally catch up with the present both
are in their winter years now and we can
see that Frank has spent a lot of time
painting this is important too as it
shows that the better side of humanity
like art and agriculture haven't died
out in the desperation he's trying to
paint bill but Judo using his motor
functions he now can't do it what about
we do close out with a painting of him
which pretty much sums up the love of
his life now these really subtle moments
like Bill giving a wing to Frank as he
paints him and watering the flowers for
the last time and at this point you
could be forgiven for thinking where not
even in a zombie apocalypse show Bill
wakes up find that Frank has decided
this will be his last day but rather
than wallowing in it they decide to make
the most of it the pair get married and
have dinner together and Frank wants to
take his pills that he can fade away
into the night hear the song on the
nature of daylight and having just
covered [__] Island in arrival for
the channel I think the creative team
were inspired by those two films both
use the piece with I think probably the
latter lending itself better to what's
going on here I'd only get two spoilery
on it but the end of the movie is about
embracing the beauty of life no matter
how heartbreaking it is which is also
reflected in this scene as well the pair
have what could be a very painful day
ahead of them but instead they're using
it as a way to celebrate their life
without dwelling on the sadness of death
that we're all gonna face one day yeah I
think that's a really solid point
because the last of us world is one that
often you think about it like it's such
a bleak world it's so dark and you know
it is such an interesting subversion
with a character like Bill if you know
the game because Bill is one of the most
hardened Ruthless People and counter the
furthest thing from welcoming right
while that's capturing the show you see
this Evolution they still find like the
purpose to live the experience the
memories that they are able to generate
together over time and that's part of
the the glory of watching an episode
like this is even in the darkest of
times they managed to find light through
human connection with one another I find
that to be such a rare thing to explore
in an apocalypse story I mean while that
that can often be there but for that to
be like a focus of a whole episode tell
such a classic beautiful tale of two
people falling in love creating a life
together of protecting each other
serving each other but also making each
other laugh all this time it was so
unexpected for this show and to also do
that for Bill but I thought it worked
perfectly even as a fan of the game I
thought we're perfectly yeah and also to
add on to just personality traits from
abilities very paranoid in the game as
well as well as we saw earlier on in
this episode I think the thing I love
the most to a lot of what you were just
saying is the emotional depth we got in
the character and both characters rather
in the relationship the way we got to
see it I just love the way how they the
the separation of time like it was just
done very well like just getting to see
their relationship Blossom and then
again in such a bleak post-apocalyptic
World which is obviously the worst of
times like something beautiful can
spiral out of that as well and again
it's probably gonna cause interesting
debate after this episode because it
didn't follow the game specifically and
obviously we didn't get you know the
Ellie and uh bill skirmishes which I'm a
sucker for but I think this episode you
know had a very beautiful theme and
message that I deeply appreciated in we
still got the version of the game so
that's good with that but again this was
so satisfying to watch that it doesn't
bother me that we didn't get an exact
replica of what happened in the game so
but I'm very curious to see how the
response is going to be yeah first of
all positive
yeah for sure Bill and reveals that he's
decided to go out with Frank rather than
continue living now this is a complete
180 on his original feelings when when
the outbreak first happened whereas
originally he wanted to survive by
himself here we see that he's grown to
the point he'd rather not live if it
meant he lost Frank at this point we
hear a song from the game that also
happens at an emotional moment in it
we'll talk about this later on in the
super spoiler section see that's the
other thing is I I love his as a
character like bill before the
apocalypse was such a lonely person who
dejected the very thought of connecting
with people he has that line in the in
the game in the show of like I was never
scared until I met you I love the irony
of how he didn't find a true connection
until most people were wiped out yeah
like it's there's something very ironic
about that I think that's that's a
beautiful story but it's very much used
in the context to show that not
everything is Bleak I think he kind of
need this moment to breathe in a show
like this as The Last of Us it can be
pretty depressing so it's nice to have
this balance of like look there is still
some good I only enjoy either Lincoln to
find the flowers starting to die and the
food on the table has started mold she
plays some notes on the piano echoing
the earlier scene and finds a letter
which mirrors the one from the game yeah
though it's a lot more positive without
Landing their lives together we learned
they laid down and went to sleep and
again I got some flashes of 28 Days
Later in that gym goes home to discover
his parents have done something similar
but they showed it there whereas a
letter wants them not to go into the
bedroom now it's addressed directly to
Joe and bill says that though he hated
the world there was one person worth
saving he's talking about Tessier but
now that position has of course shifted
Ellie who he's gonna go on protecting we
get a focus on the sentence about
keeping tests safe which is pretty
devastating because gels of course
failed to do this instead of confronting
the grief though he immediately leaves
and takes his mind off it by crumpling
up the ladder just in the same way that
this get a scene in which they
discovered the truck and left at the
front Joe also checks the fridge which
has sulfuric acid in it Jill asks to see
her arm and this could be teasing at
somehow we'll discuss so no spoilers
because I'll get i'll get tons of
comments but super small section now in
the basement we discover why there was
80's music playing on the radio at the
end of episode one Bill had it set up so
that if he didn't reset the countdown
then it was just gonna play 80s
constantly on a loop this would of
course signal that they were in danger
and we'll get Tess and Gerald to come
out to where they were now it is
possible that Bell knew this would
happen anyway which is why he of course
addressed the letter Joel I do have a
quick Through Time new Time new time so
Joe and Tess they'd been searching
desperately for a car battery so that
they could get to Tommy originally in
the game they sell guns to Robert but
the whole thing in the show revolved
around getting a battery for a truck
bill of course has one and I think that
he might have had the 80s music on Loop
so that they were gonna come out looking
for him he left down the keys for the
truck because he possibly knew that they
needed one and thus this is very much
his last bill and testament to get them
with the ride that they've been looking
for anyway that's in a few times and we
can see Ellie sorry you have to let that
[Music]
sorry I have to let it play out
right as I was saying you don't
it's gonna be stuck in my head for a
while as I was saying the pair get some
clothes and Ellie slips into the red
t-shirt that she wore throughout the
game she also finds a handgun and I
believe it's the same model as the one
she carries in the source material Jill
gives it to her a nap but here she takes
it behind his back which might cause
some issues later on she all comes out
finally wearing the green checkered
shirt that he does throughout the
majority of this story and you might
have noticed Frank wearing this earlier
in the episode they're getting the car
together and originally in the game he
had a much tensor scene in which you had
to jump start it Jill and Bill had to
push it as the infected sworn whilst
Ellie sat in the ride attempting to pop
the clutch love the little touch of her
not knowing to wear a seatbelt and
together they head out as she discovers
the tape in the glove box no points for
guessing what the song is and we watch
them right out to Linda ronsten's long
long time we close out to an open window
with a picture of Bill hanging up which
takes us into our super super spoiler
section I was thinking this now for this
bit I will be talking about elements
that appear in both games they don't end
it well one of them's an ending rooner
but there are some moments in Easter
eggs in the episode that will probably
spoil things down the line here at this
point I'd really love you guys if you
hit the thumbs up on the way out and
make sure you subscribe to not miss our
breakdowns in episode 4. thanks right
what a [__] [__] I play their games
well they're bloody hell is wrong with
you anyway the open window has a lot of
big moments in the game it's the menu
screen for the first one and in part two
it's also the last shot as Ellie walks
away that summed up the end of her story
and here it's very much summing up the
ending of Bill and Frank's a Mortal
Kombat 2 cabinet is pretty important as
well and I think it's something that's
going to return in the series later on
it ties in massively with the writing
story and in the DLC left behind you
played on the Turning cabinet alongside
Riley my guess is that they'll do
something similar on the Riley flashback
and have them imagining what it's like
to play Mortal Kombat 2 wasting money
getting their asses
monkey and how she bets that they spread
the cordyceps monkeys actually show up
in the game how we end up encountering
them when we enter the university turns
out the fireflies were experimenting on
them to find a cure to them being so
close to us on a DNA level might not
have been a connection to that but with
monkeys potentially appearing down the
line I thought I'd bring that line up it
better be some [__] monkeys it could
also be something as well with that
being administered in the series in part
two when Ellie and Dina bunker down she
ends up showing her her arm we discover
that Ellie did a chemical burn on the
bite using sulfuric acid and this was
then covered up with a tattoo once it
healed Ellie got sick of constantly
having to hide her arm so she carried
this out once it became clear that The
Cure thing wasn't gonna oh yeah you get
what could be a nod to the spaceship
scene in that a thousand people he talks
about the car being like a spaceship and
in part two she all takes le2 museum for
her birthday
and then Ellie imagines what it's like
traveling into space anyway that wraps
up the breakdown and I think this
episode kind of transcended the
Apocalypse to tell a love story this is
something that's been at the heart of
the show and in the official podcast for
episode 1 they said that the show was
very much going to be discussing the
positives and negatives of Love yeah
it's a more wholesome Outlook but in the
case of Joel and Ali we see how
dangerous it is Joel begins to love
Ellie like she's his own daughter and
because of this he Dooms Humanity by
killing the fireflies in order to save
her life so we have this idea that love
can be a good thing but also that it has
its negatives as well especially if
someone stands in the way of it I think
this was important to explore with Bill
and Frank and it'll probably massively
influence the future episodes even if
it's not obvious now it's a big
deviation from the game so whether
people prefer that or not is gonna be
something I think they're gonna be going
back and forth over I think this stuff
in the game works better as a level
because you travel through the graveyard
the school and then you fight a blower
in it kind of rams up to your boss which
I think works in a game and the show
kinda really needed to do something
different so they focused on character
development gave us a bit of a breather
so it wasn't all doom and gloom and they
also managed to make one of the side
characters way more fleshed out I
enjoyed it and so far I think we've had
three really really strong episodes I
know there's kind of back and forth at
the moment but let me know your thoughts
below and again thank you for rocking
with me of course thank you and thank
you for getting the three times three
times three times stuck in my head yeah
but that was great video I mean so much
of this show yeah of course exploring
the positives and negatives of Love is
an everlasting theme in The Last of Us
uh it's so prevalent throughout both of
the games we can have our muddied
interpretations of what we do for love
and in the Name of Love what
consequences that can lead down so yeah
I think that's a a great thing to
constantly be exploring and to make it
such a something that's really on the
surface for audiences to really attain
to obviously the monkey reference I made
earlier
that was obviously the one I was making
yeah yeah but uh no I agree with
everything you said and I also agree
with Paul I think again I love that they
this episode took a little more of a
slow burn just getting more fleshed out
with these characters especially a
character like Bill who's not fleshed
out in the game in any other way other
than we know a few character traits and
just that he's really hard sure and that
kind of thing but like to get me this
emotionally vested in in such a side
character that I just thought was you
know just a hard ass badass type of
character in the side character in the
video game I just I thought it was a
really smart move for for the TV show
and again the levels play out better in
the game but this plays out better in
the TV show so I thought it was again A
very wise and smart decision to do at
the end of the day you actually
technically get more bill in the show
more than you do in the game it's just
you're you're playing levels with bills
so it feels like you might have more
bill but that's not the case you get way
more story on Bill here than you do at
all in the game so yeah and the
characters yeah way more fleshed out I
mean you get obvious basically action
sequences with Bill in the video game
whereas here you get a lot more
character development with I think one
action sequence and I gotta say too
really quick before we let this go we
probably talked about in our reaction
video I absolutely loved that scene that
they had with the four of them at the
table right and just little character
traits where pills got the like his hand
on the trigger while he's eating yeah
like I'm like that is just so Bill like
just the paranoia so bill so bill
um but yeah uh no that was a great
episode and also to the makeup that they
did with anatova with Tess like just
making her look so much younger and then
also how the Aged out Bill and Frank is
just all around just a great episode
phenomenal stuff phenomenal work heavy
spoilers you're becoming a super wealthy
rich man with these videos and I'm happy
to see it happen to one of the best guys
I know out there guys subscribe to heavy
spoilers if you haven't done so already
and hey let's send this with shouting
out
hey thanks for joining me here John oh
no problem Rachel Reardon you got a
great song out there danger Jeffrey
Robinson danger she didn't he never
heard that before real in the Joss
save myself
Barca fan 101 my my favorite kind of
lounge chair Roberto Angela man you did
damn
Angelo 10 Downing Street
Ian decastica Neil Simon Shanghai Noon
Shanghai Jacob Neptune Kayla the cop oh
King the Conqueror
Kelly King Mitchell Reed Richards no
more boobs all Anne Ling James Howlett
burden I wanna get a bureau with Kira
Eric Khan's 39.
doesn't like to do 69s the football
number because YouTube's weird
goosey-goosey dance in the batuci nick
triple x uh Ice Cube one long two Gory
for YouTube uh Gail weathers Craig
Ferguson Mohammed is the most commonly
used name on Earth Al sharani Jaron big
wanner stiff Cliff Rodriguez Aaron
Michael Myers Master Thief
John
the goat
big boat full of hoes Tron magic
Infinity Jared Leto let's do it it's a
disaster when you're around Lorenzo
Baxter but really it's not it makes life
go faster nothing is plain when you're
chilling with differently sane Marco
tunn still loves to kill oh
look out use the force Lauren American
Horse simply faded is uh not the name of
a chili pepper song that is so much
faded Joanna Banna of bobana Saint Luigi
Rogue Willy
slow jam 94. Justin Cartman pour me a
glass of Rose
you got it Rachel oh bro Alden Aaron
wreck semi-calling Phillips screwdriver
Junior Jen and the Holograms Smith
Melody committing a felony while
drinking a Hennessy in public
alrighty guys thank you so much for
being part of our patreon page and
showing that support it means the world
to have you here it's uh one of the best
ways to help keep this channel afloat so
thank you for being here again hope to
see at least 99 of you in February if
one of you goes
that's fine
but no more than one but there can only
be one if you leave you gotta find a
replacement
yes Ms the rules
all right watch this video conclude
[Music]